so what we've got here is a couple of
open moco neo free runners now this is
an open source Linux based phone and
it's not quite ready for primetime yet
we would definitely not recommend going
out and buying this as your primary
phone but it's pretty interesting
because this project is all totally
everything on this phone is customizable
every single thing that's customizable
from the base to the operating system to
anything you can create a game for it
one of those that love to complain about
my cell phone sucks and I can't do this
I can't do that well get yourself a
developers book some programming right
you know get the Linux base and then you
can start working on your own phone now
the this is definitely our Lee days for
this phone well what the makers of this
open moko have told us is that this
phone the hardware is basically there
but the operating system is you know
maybe 60% there let's take a look at the
interface on that one and compare it
because it's tough it's a totally
different look than what we've got on
this other phone right right so there
were three different types of operating
systems that neo has been working on for
the last few months this was the second
version there was an earlier version we
actually have a third phone here but
it's not turning off now there are some
things I like about the hardware the
screen is a good size it's about the
same size as an iPhone screen and the
shape actually it's pretty interesting I
think I think actually the shape comes
across better in person than it does in
the photographs at the scene of the neo
before because there's something about
this it feels a little bit like I don't
know bar soap or something but it's so
yeah it's comfortable in the hand sort
of cute looking but just this design I
think this is a nice screen like you
said good touch capabilities although it
does not have the multi-touch of vehicle
they relate only exactly so you can only
you can't go into a map you know and in
pain there's no pinching in this one
okay and check this out
is a little
here on the bottom so if you want to
like tie a strap on to it and hang it
around your neck and look like a dork
yeah well you know this is the icon for
this for a GPS system and as you can see
it immediately takes us to a location
which is incorrect Tokyo so what's the
bottom line Jose I should I go out and
buy one of these and what's it cost I
think for us I think we could buy one it
cost $400 but the bottom line is that
this is a customizable you know machine
you can customize everything from the
casing to the operating system like
we've said before you could actually
create like you know a casing of a rock
or completely crystal or whatever you
want
I love the idea of a linux-based phone
that's encased in rock because that way
when it crashes and it doesn't boot up
then at least you can still use the rock
to like bash things open exactly don't
you have like a rock in your pants
always or to throw your colleagues
mm-hmm no maybe that's just you Jose I'm
sorry so I'm not quite ready for
consumers we're not quite ready for
consumers but another developer who
takes this might take it and make it a
little more consumer friendly I think
that's what we're gonna see but the body
the system's the guts of this thing is
really special and I think the
developers are gonna love it and you
could have you know a lot of the
different applications are going to come
out of this and it will benefit a lot of
the consumers later on maybe not this
year but definitely in the next year
cool